На околиці Берліна розташований найбільший в Європі притулок для тварин.
Тут утримують близько півтори тисячі котів, собак, кроликів,
папуг, змій, ігуан і навіть мавп.
Приблизно половину тварин здають у притулок громадяни,
іншу половину - митниця і поліція.
На першому місці за чисельністю - кішки.
Причому для кожного вольєра - індивідуальний набір для прибирання.
Це зроблено з метою профілактики поширення захворювань.
У Німеччині немає бродячих собак, але чимало бездомних кішок.
У всіх великих містах Німеччини багато безпритульних котів.
Вони, у порівнянні з південними країнами,
не надто впадають у вічі. І все ж вони є.
Лише в Берліні їхня популяція сягає 10 тисяч.
Ми про них піклуємося.
В Берліні в нас є 245 пунктів підкорму,
е на місяць роздаємо 17 тисяч котячих консерв.
А якщо біля годівниці знаходимо травмовану чи хвору тварину,
ми забираємо її до притулку, лікуємо та повертаємо назад.
Крім котів і собак, у притулку утримується чимало екзотичних тварин.
Наприклад, мавпи, яких використовували для наукових експериментів.
Є також папуги на будь-який смак і колір.
І навіть велика зелена ігуана, якій важко знайти нового господаря.
Притулок фінансується виключно за рахунок приватних пожертв:
щороку потрібно понад 8 мільйонів євро.
Бюджет такий великий, бо до нас надходить багато хворих тварин,
наприклад, з вадами серця.
Їм потрібні дорогі медикаменти та регулярні медичні обстеження.
Щоб дати тварині шанс знайти нового власника,
притулок бере на себе витрати на медичне обслуговування
тварин із хронічними захворюваннями.
Ну а футуристична архітектура притулку приваблює кінематографістів.
Час від часу вони знімають тут фільми.
Усього в притулку три павільйони для котів
та п’ять для собак. А також ветеринарна клініка,
павільйони для птахів та екзотичних тварин.
А поруч - кладовище для домашніх тварин.
Місце тут коштує від 150 до 250 євро.
Але це вже зовсім інша історія.